Now, I imagine you might have suspected that this was the best answer.
Look at the geometry of a sphere and find a clever way to calculate this circumference.
Now, you may have been tempted by this one,
but, well, yes in science it is generally good to take a lot of data.
That's a great habit to be in.
But if every single piece of data you're taking is just a wild guess with no real reason to believe it,
this isn't going to help.
This one's a little impractical--wrapping a string around the earth--
and there's no reason to believe the moon and the earth have the same circumference,
not to mention, how do we calculate the circumference of the moon?
This leaves geometry, which means this is a job for math.
Let's go to Florence to learn a little more about Eratosthenes' approach to
to measuring the circumference of the earth.